barak a dit on va faire une review
bernard vous pensez à quoi en ce moment
là
j'ai bien ouais content de voir ma fille
devra vous je suis foutu bien quand vous
vous regardez le matin dans la glace
vous dites quoi bernard
le seul moment où je me regarde dans la
glace moment où je me rase et
franchement je me parle pas dans ce
moment là que la journée d'accord dans
la journée ça va arrive sur bagnols tous
je vous dis allez vas-y mon gars il tord
ont par exemple
vous auriez aimé ressembler à qui quand
vous étiez petit bernard bas comme tout
le monde ça dépend de l'âge à quel âge
pas vers 12 ans là quand on commence à
12 ans
12 ans mel ferrer mel ferrer et parce
qu'ils sautaient audrey hepburn j'étais
fidèle et ça se comprend notre plus
belle histoire d'amour bah c'est la
seule avec ma femme ça fait 32 dans quel
but
c'est beau à 32 20
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les gens ont
perdu un peu le sens du couple quoi
c'est la première difficulté ils
divorcent quoi c'est vrai oui mais il ya
des couples c'est vraiment un coup de
bol parce que
tu vois bien il ya des gens pleins de
bonne volonté on va pas se forcer quoi
c'est pas quelque chose qui peut jamais
mais vouloir la vérité cela il faut
quand même le vous voilà il faut dire je
veux réussir et il ya des passages
difficiles et souvent on s'aperçoit que
si tu sur mon fils il en y mettant un
peu du sien obtus repas voilà nous on a
été vraiment vachement bien pendant
vingt ans sans aucun problème puis on a
commencé à rentrer dans l'habitude et la
turne a eu sauf un et sophie nous a
redonné un coup incroyable parce qu'on
s'est retrouvé nouveaux parents avec les
problèmes d'un enfant en bas âge et c
est là tout va bien ah ouais super est
ce que vous seriez prêt à tout quitter
pour le pantalon sur demain dans la rue
vous tombez sur une base s mais fou
d'amour je la mère de ma femme j'ai tout
poil avait déjà fait j'ai arrêté de
bosser un kit à lire quand on s'est
connus on a arrêté l'un et l'autre de
bosser on a vécu sur nos économies et on
a vécu neuf mois rien fait d'autre rien
d'autre que manger dormir et tagada
tsoin
après il y ait plus de thunes lille
rennes qu'on bosse quand est-ce que vous
avez pleuré pour la dernière fois à
berlin
quand j'ai vu dans ma loge avait pas les
30000 euros promis
les a mis dans un trou singes qui était
pas j'ai chialé on l'a fait football
mais tu n'en veux pas vous changeriez
quoi en vous si vous aviez une baguette
magique ma date de naissance ouais ah
ouais qu'est ce que vous pourriez dire
de plus négatif sur vous
et tu crois pas qu'il en est et si dit
comme ça sans
moi j'ai été gâté quand on m'a retiré on
m'a privé de mes droits civiques on m'a
privé mais droit parental on m'a
interdit de sport on m'a interdit de
politique on m'interdit d'affaires on
m'a dit vas tu mens refais toi
authentique ils ont cru que j'allais
d'ailleurs pas refaire jamais
il y avait un moment où vous êtes dit je
vais jamais y arriver à me refaire
aurait plusieurs fois un
et justement si vous deviez était à
refaire qu'est-ce que vous changeriez de
sexe ah ouais bah oui j'ai connu mec
maintenant j'aimerais connaître
tu as envie de te rattraper
vous seriez vous soyez un peu effet
c'est pour ça que je te dise à
qui avez-vous le plus envie d'épater
dans la vue ah c'est un truc que j'ai
jamais aimé ça hein j'ai jamais aimé et
pathé o bernard je veux donner deux
exemples
j'avais un beau bateau jamais personne
n'a pu monter dessus voir une photo de
l'intérieur de mon bateau on n'était
jamais ailleurs que loin
il a été acheté par une femme on a vu la
chambre à coucher la salle à manger les
dîners les le pot de géraniums sur la
rn6 à épater c'est-à-dire non moi j'aime
je sais pas c'est pas j'aime bien j'ai
bien surprendre j'aime bien être et mais
j'aime bien ça mais j'aime pas épaté
alors deuxième exemple le bateau c'était
le premier c'est quoi le deuxième
exemple mon la maison d'accord personne
est rentré faire des photos dans la
musique si les chiens 8e il n'a pas fait
de photos il a piqué les meubles
qu'est ce que vous feriez si vous restez
24 heures à vivre un crédit
je crois que je réglerai quelques
comptes quand même quand même vrai juste
avant de partir et d'avoir un il y en a
quelques-uns qui sont pas soldés encore
il ya encore deux trois bourre pif dans
l'air et ouais il ya 2-3 et une tournée
à faire est-ce que vous avez déjà pensé
au suicide oui une fois en présent non
non non c'était dehors et grâce à la
halle à à la présence d'esprit de ma
femme c'est ça s'est pas fait qu'est ce
que la vie vous a appris d'un tapis qui
le pire n'est jamais certain oui
comment aimeriez-vous mourir
bonjour away enterré incinérés un vrai
qu'on va enterrer vivant comment
descendre à non non je m'en fous
sagement complète j'ai pas peur de ça du
touch croyants
j'ai pas fait trop de mal enfin
contrairement à ce qu'on a dit a pas
tellement de gens qui ont souffert et
donc à la fin du parcours je pense
qu'ils me dire allez bien il était temps
que tu arrives
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux